and you know here you are you're the
grandfather of the internet and all of
that but you know I'm not gonna We Won't
dwell on that but I do think I do think
that you have some very interesting
perspective about uh you know you spend
now several years in Japan uh as an
expat right and you see
a whole tremendous range of people who
come tracing through and talk and bring
ideas to you and uh
then uh they get those ideas get planted
in other people and you you know you're
uh you're a seed to the um the whole
networking system and you know I think
that that's
um
that's one of the
one of the things that you do when you
get over a certain age is to plant new
uh new ideas in people uh the fact that
you didn't in Japan as opposed to the
U.S struck me as being uh always stopped
me as being very brave
ah
yes I mean it's
that's that Japanese culture which I I
have some understanding of is very
different than U.S culture and
particularly in the scientific area
yes yes it is intriguing let me let me
maybe spend a few minutes
mumbling about how I got here okay
as you know uh for many many years maybe
40 some odd years I've been
periodically coming to Japan and as
initially as uh you know just
inquisitiveness I had the professor ISO
uh when he was an assistant professor
came over and worked with I think it was
the DCS project so that established a
reasonably firm contact in academic
Japan as well as other things uh make a
Gigi and I uh spent three months here
once at the digital library project
which as far as I can tell went nowhere
at least I don't see it but it may have
gone
um and then uh five years ago uh Gerald
came from Kokomo over in New York he was
in New York and he said could we get
together I said sure I was living in
Manhattan at that point enjoying living
in New York for a while and um he said
we'd like you to come to Japan
uh for a year and no Henry Lord and
talked about that sounded interesting uh
as you know Gigi had passed away by then
and so I said yes I'll come for you
and so I came
to Mariah and I and churro started the
Cyber civilization Research Center at Ko
University
in a small but remarkably influential in
a way uh so I came over and uh and got a
very nice house rented to me by the
hospital KO hospital and uh
started Living in Japan
since I was only coming home for a year
I I
spent a minimum amount of time trying to
learn Japanese
uh you know it's a huge investment as
you know
especially being able to read Japanese
I've gotten some capability of speaking
but not that much because again most of
my contacts are either very good
Japanese which is hard or people who
speak English which are not that many
unfortunately
um
and then towards the end of the year I
we sort of came about maybe I was
staying over here
and that's been going on for five years
and I may do it I do may do it a little
more yeah
uh it looks like I'll probably staying
over a couple of years
Japan is is a very interesting culture
it's totally different as you well know
from the United States
uh
if I had to look at differences
um I find that a large number of
Japanese researchers
abilities to speak
English or any language of it in Japan
it's about the same as the American
Research of speaking anything of it in
English
most non-existent
the problem is that uh unfortunately the
Royal speaks English a small piece that
speaks Japanese
so that that causes really interesting
issues
uh
it's uh culturally and educationally
it's it's a very interesting uh very
interesting Society but it's um it's an
island nation
and it has all the properties of an
island nation as far as adapting
um
language and and culture to agree it's a
wonderful place to live
uh if you have people
if you have enough contacts in English
from uh scientific standpoint
there are problems I will be not sure
not
giving the wrong impression to say
everything is smooth many of the uh
organizations which normally I'd contact
work with
um I speak only Japanese and so there's
uh you know if an English only speaker
and a Japanese speaking uh World their
limitations
uh people go out of their way to try
uh to help but you know again the the uh
there are some issues I've been totally
enjoyed and I you know luckily enough
people especially at Ko the uh
sfc campus it has a large number of
English speakers
uh
however working with the Japanese
government is very difficult
in the sense that again it's it's a
language
problem we don't I remember many years
ago uh president of NTT but maybe I
think it was NTT said that his goal in
life was to pick up a phone in Japan
talk to somebody in the United States
and have the computer automatically
Translate
we're not there yet
we we can have it automatically
mistranslate quite well well can we in
Zoom
can I uh I don't know I I did Rick what
she'd showed me a uh uh a little snippet
of a conversation that he'd had in
Chinese
uh a couple years ago five ten years ago
I have yet to find a commercial product
uh like Zoom which would allow me to
carry on
a meeting with foreign language people
and English-speaking people who talk to
each other over a remote connection
yeah I think you're right and that that
seems to me to be a something that has
to be cured
um
anyway uh by the way that brings up an
interesting issue which isn't something
we could talk a little more about if
you're interested there was an article
in Nikkei which is one that makes papers
as you know saying that many Japanese
software companies have switched to the
use of English within the company
because they can't find enough Japanese
computer scientists software people to
work
and so they they want to import they
have to import people and again the only
way they can make them viable is to it
just makes company speak English
which yes which says a couple of things
but you know let me let me emphasize
that I thoroughly enjoy living here it's
a totally different culture very
pleasant uh people are very helpful uh
I've never bumped into anything other
than helpful people
that's all five years
uh
almost every aspect transportation in
Tokyo expect in Japan is spectacular
food is excellent uh prices are uh
reasonable
especially if you convert to Dallas now
so it's been an interesting uh students
are
interesting I found some excellent
students I teach voluntarily teach one
course I don't have to as in the
arrangements we had but to be at a
university and not teach is just silly
in my personal opinion and I found some
really good students
um
good Japanese students some of which
I've said to the U.S for their phds
yeah
so it's uh if you've been teaching
undergraduates I've been teaching an
upper division uh graduate program
on sort of issues and cyber civilization
looking at technology issues ETC
somewhat similar to what you teach in
the sense that I've I have visitors come
in
uh quote come in and uh to have this the
kids read stuff in advance
uh there's uh the person comes in and
makes uh
a fairly brief presentation then we open
up the discussion
and uh
depending on the students in the class
uh you get very active discussions this
year has been particularly good since
Japan opened up to open up to having
students come from abroad which they
hadn't doing anything coming and they're
much more Pro and task questions and
once they asked questions Japanese
students feel comfortable and so it's
been a pleasant experience teaching
and some of them are excellent
uh
let's see what
does that spark any others
yeah I think that
I don't know the teaching in the US is
uh
um I think less is less exciting than it
has been
uh yeah it's
it's been five years since I've taught
in the U.S five six years actually well
a little more than that
um
yeah probably the u.s's uh
teaching is getting what may be less
exciting and research has gotten more
exciting in the academic world
and especially true in in major
institutions
that the uh the attention rate to
teaching is
gone down uh you know all too often when
I we reviewed the promotions Etc uh he
had to be tolerable in teaching and you
had to be exceptionally good in research
and that that whole uh attitude towards
teaching uh sort of
soaks the whole environment and Japan is
is not that way they they sort of expect
you to be
to teach
um
it's not the same as American teaching
uh
and or probably some European teaching
uh it's uh but the
the teaching I think is taken much more
importantly here but there's not a
rating system I can find it at least it
may be one but I've never been exposed
to it
uh but uh
you know the thing I like teaching is
that that it exposes me to
young people when you with young ideas
and uh you know and people who are
willing to explore new new Arenas that
they haven't touched
and uh that's getting hotter and hot to
do in the U.S with the
whole host of reasons
which I can operate on if you'd like of
course but the the the the I have a
question and to sneak in here
do people study anything other than
artificial intelligence these days in
Japan
yeah yeah
ai ai
I was sort of
nobody studies artificial intelligence
these sorry machine learning
they say it's artificial intelligence
ethics or you know one of the one of the
social sciences which relate to valuing
things yeah I uh I used to work with
with Al nuhu and the and um Kurt Simon
Etc when they were really trying to do
AI
and what's done now is not the same
intent or the same path that they were
down I think it's it's
some good work being done in in machine
learning uh whatever you want to call it
machine assistant decision making
uh but I don't see very much done in
real ala
the classical AI but that's
that's fine uh yeah uh AI actually does
not have I keep using that term because
it's shorter than than the other one AI
is is I don't think that's Central at
least at kale
uh there's a lot of
water work being done in uh
medical informatics security systems of
course uh Quantum computing
uh
Etc uh
and and
um I want to call it um uh
the uh the new Financial mechanisms in
computer science
uh crypto coinage but while crypto
mechanisms blockchains
systems and for inventory control
Etc uh Japan is is
going to start I think a crypto Cur uh a
uh government crypto coin next year the
government and banking uh but I don't
see again
one of the problems with being a
non-japanese speaker is the newspapers I
read in the English language papers
which really don't address many of the
issues that Japanese address but I don't
see a huge amount of
uh enthusiasm for a
for the
cryptocurrency but it may be there
I know the first time I saw a crypto uh
a Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin um
uh ATM machine was in a uh one of the
big uh computer stores in Japan
uh which I think it's still yeah I never
saw anybody use it but it's still there
uh you know the the
when I first used to come to Japan I
used to go to the yakihabara which is
you know sort of computer land back then
that's completely changed now so I think
the Japanese
and the world has accepted computers as
sort of a standard thing that they use
and while they're still hobbyist shops
and still people interested in it it's
it's changed dramatically
as to the cryptocurrency I I don't see
I don't see the the noise that I hear in
the rest of the world but it may be here
again I don't watch
Japanese YouTube because I can't
understand it
I could watch
even though actually even Japanese used
to propose a huge amount of English in
it
because you want to be able to rest uh
the uh
Japanese government has put a fair
amount of money into research in in
crypto into security
uh you know a major effort the Japanese
government has been this uh information
training with with trust that's not the
official title but it's close to it
and uh the problem I've always seen is
that you know we're we're women in a
world where hard or anything we touch
could be trusted
that's right and and yet people uh still
believe they can trust it
yes which is sort of very strange
the uh when you talk about uh
medical information to say uh with trust
uh how do you do that if you can't trust
what's below you
I don't know
um
and that's that's uh that is
that leads me into a sort of saying that
I've been spending a fair amount of time
or worrying about it and that's the fact
that we've we really haven't addressed
the the you know you talked about the
network being the internet being sort of
Standards like our electrical system
right I think we hopefully we can trust
the electrical system more than I
believe we could trust the internet
[Music]
um
and in the in the world we're in now
that that lack of trust is going to be
very harmful
uh I'll give you an example of what what
worries me
um
there was a member of the uh
high in the in the governing party of
Japan the liberal Democrat ldp has been
uh enforced for almost ever
in Japan
uh and one of the relatively senior
members was talking about cyber attacks
on Japan and he he said you know if
we're ever attacked we should
instantaneously respond
okay yeah thanks uh you have any idea
how you find out who attacks you
know
why nobody in the technical I mean I can
I can find oh it's how to do it but in
fact uh the governments believe you can
do it
uh
and that's just part of the headache
um
Japan has been uh really impacted by a
number of
uh maximum attacks ransomware
penetrations
Etc and it I think it's time to do
something about that
um yeah I have my own my own belief on
how to address it and I think
it's not going to be a popular statement
but I think I think you have to rethink
things
yep uh you know the internet and and uh
suddenly the internet was a research
project
and I was in on the very early stages
that
nobody particularly worried about
security it's a small group of people
that were laying the foundation
and
making it resilient to attack or Etc
just wasn't that big an issue
the issue was really getting it to work
right but yet those baked in all those
initial assumptions initial mechanisms
baked in
um they're very hard to work around
you know so I I really think it's time
to
really take a look at what's there and
see how how to really even evolve it or
rip it up and start over again
yeah as you know starting over again
isn't easy but I think you can you can
do it in an intelligent fashion that
doesn't obsolete things but create
starts creating a more robust framework
but anyway
uh enough of that for a minute
you mean you mean anti-fragile these
days right like tell them
you mean
anti-fragilism's uh hierarchy of
robustness rather than robust yeah yes
yeah you wanted to recover no matter
what
yeah uh oh yeah
software is hard
Hardware is even hard as you know
Hardware Hardware is getting to be even
harder because pieces of it get uh get
stuck in uh at various times yes and uh
you know I spent a long time Consulting
for a company I will not mention here
uh
in the valley and uh
boy she's gotten complicated
and uh software has gotten even more
complicated
uh you know you just watch the arrival
Raiders mostly security patches to
assist Mike apples iOS
and it began to come in one week
and that's addressing the bottom the the
stuff that Apple supports and this is
true of all the manufacturers
uh the inter-rival rate of patches most
of which are security patches
is just extremely it's getting more and
more and that that's what it suggests
that
with all the work we've done so it's uh
improving software correctness
Etc we're still far from the way we
created a very complex environment and
it's hard to control
it's true do you think that you think
that there's uh uh a uh willingness to
make major changes to any uh anything
these days
foreign
I think it's going to be forced on
people
not voluntary it's it would be an
expensive project I think there are a
couple of research activities which may
pan out May pan out
um
the the one that Peter Neumann and um
and Cambridge are doing uh Sherry I
guess it's called Sherry is yeah is an
interesting approach it's
it's not a new approach by the way as
you know oh yeah no it's but and also
many people think that uh it's
vulnerable to many of the same attacks
that everything else is is vulnerable to
but at least they acknowledge the fact
that they are being attacked yes yes and
and I took part in several
computer architectures which were trying
to be secure
uh
it's hot
you know I was part of the multex
project if you remember that oh yes I
remember
uh that was pretty that ended up pretty
secure
given the given what it was doing
uh
but the headache is that as we won the
headaches as we've gotten
commodity operating systems like Mac OS
Windows Etc
any changes to those become extremely
expensive and difficult
and so if you come up with an architect
uh Hardware architecture which you
believe could be much more secure much
more trustable
uh changing the software to run on it is
very expensive and often impossible to
do
uh
and that would be true and to the point
where we we suddenly realize that not to
do something is too expensive
and how do we measure that what do we
find that point
it's clearly not attacks I think I
personally think that where the the
um where that's going to arrive is when
we realize that we're an environment now
where a
nation-state will use
the vulnerability of the software to
compromise its opponents
and uh
that that is going to be a very
expensive proposition unless we do
something about it
you know years ago uh
oh it must be eight nine years ago a
bunch of uh old fogies and I do read all
fogies yeah I was 71 at that point so
that's uh 12 years ago 13 years ago met
at the Army Navy golf club for lunch
and the question was very simple one do
we know do we have in place an
understanding of how what will happen
when we get cyber attacks which attack
critical infrastructure
do we have have policy makers under the
escalation that can take place
no no yes and these are capital letters
both face type
these were people who I would put names
on but they were senior people I was a
junior person in the act
okay all by the way ex-rated people
what went around which I think says
something about and we had all most of
us have been there around Herman Khan's
point
um
but I think that's going to be more and
more the driving force
because the way it is now we are very
vulnerable
well you know the the promise of the
internet was you really to make uh
communication uh uh sort of go away in
some sense that is to say we're sitting
here you're in Tokyo I'm in uh Northern
California and it's it's just a matter
of time shifting a little bit for each
of us yeah with let me let me captivize
that a slightly different way it was to
make the cost of communication go away
you know uh and it would
and to make it more convenient and more
ubiquitous
there were so many networks around uh
with different protocols which worked
but they didn't easily into communicate
so and uh
you know all of us back then were
suffering from expensive telephones to
talk to each other
so there were a lot of motivations but I
think besides ubiquitous it's the word
it was bring down the cost and the and
also to make it easier
and so you know we couldn't have done
this even if we had the technology
uh 20 years ago 20 or 30 years ago we
didn't have the communication
infrastructure where it would let us do
this
although I would comment that remember
they see you see me
how many years ago was that I don't
remember but it was quite a long time
ago and uh it's just recently we caught
up to where that was and we also had the
great forgetfulness which is systemic in
this uh where was I okay
um
but uh
now I think we even even the network now
um and works and works quite well and it
doesn't work
it's vulnerable in a funny way
and a majority of traffic now is carried
by undersea cable
undersea cable is very very fragile
uh it's also tappable and uh
easily broken and
um
Etc broken uh satellites we don't quite
have a bandwidth for the type of stuff
that the public uses I assume the
military is in better shape
maybe but uh
I think the other thing is that the
the way well let me I I will probably
get killed for the following statement
okay okay
we can snip it out if you want it no let
me let me try it you can snip anything
out you want uh
the network was both
was architect when we had relatively
slow relatively unreliable circuits
okay
we're now in a position where we have
very high speed
very reliable Communications and at the
ends of those Communications we have
computers which
in a funny way have a have all the
computing power you want
but yet the architecture of the internet
was
was uh
based on the first set of assumptions
and we're in the second world now so if
you if you had if you redesigned things
now would you use small packets
would you the type of recovery systems
we have no or would use ever correcting
codes for the occasional time you you
had an error which is relatively
infrequently it usually it's there or
it's not well it works
and what would that do to the whole
environment
uh I think it's an interesting question
uh
you know I I talked a little bit uh
maybe 50 years ago I did a little bit of
thinking of that and I've been thinking
of it more now in this in the context of
how do you rebuild what we have now to
make it more secure and trustable
right
well I don't know how you do it but it
definitely needs to be done
and that's just the bottom layer and the
next layers all need to be redone a
little bit too I think yes uh
I think we could do a fair amount uh
in
yeah each way in each layer of the of
our infrastructure needs to be looked at
and and sometimes redesigned sometimes
fixed there's a big difference I think
you can do that in a in a smooth way
where you don't you know the old problem
was how could I redesign things because
uh if I did you know there millions and
millions of people out there with uh PCS
and running Windows Etc so I can't touch
it yeah but that's not the case you're
concern we build a new infrastructure
which is compatible with the old one
essentially emulates the old one if you
want
so people could continue to operate I
think that's perfectly reasonable
approach uh software is a big problem
uh
I don't know how to fix that one easily
uh
every time we we say we we now have a
new attack on it and we we sort of up
the old ideas the new ones get
convoluted too too much
uh I think maybe if we if we redesign
the whole environment
and again I think you can do this in a
in a smooth way that doesn't disrupt the
millions of people who are happy sitting
on their little Windows machines or
whatever they sit on
but would service the critical
infrastructure the banking systems Etc
in fact one one of my uh
one of my quote customers for redesign
would be the banking system because it's
it's somewhat of a
mess is nice to White term
uh give you an example of the problems
if I can about eight years ago the NSF
organized meeting in New York but they
took a small set of people attending
that I forget forget some networking
conference and we went off to talk to
people
uh four groups what one representative
will actually do a three I think uh the
the people who ran
several large banking systems in New
York and one person from Fort Meade
okay
it was interesting uh he was allowed to
say something too uh and they just
described the environment they're in
and there was things like well we have
our computers but we're afraid to touch
them
because we don't have source code we
don't know what's in it
the Hardware's uh sort of fikey half the
time and we just sort of sit back and
pray
and this happened if you remember the
the riot of looking for Cobalt
programmers
right because in fact nobody knows
what's in those machines anymore they've
been patched the patches have been
patched and patches have been patched so
all you have is is basically something
that you pray you can run
the the guy from Fort Meade commented
that one machine which was used to
produce the this was on classified media
so I could use to produce the daily
security summary for the president
uh he was afraid to touch it the he had
no idea in the world of of how he'd fix
the hardware if it broke
right and he had poor she had had no
clean code that he could transmit to a
new generation computer well that's
weird because that's all written in
small talk
quite amusing of course maybe the small
talk didn't survive into the Modern Age
that could be that could be uh
and yet you know pushing into this is
just aside
the economics of of using
um I'll call it distribute systems
which is really what the the web-based
architectures
Etc are
is probably the way you want to go
it's it's an idea which I I you know I
helped Pioneer with the DCS project yeah
I think it's a good idea it's probably
an efficient idea but fitting that into
what we have now really
is sometimes very difficult oh yeah
yeah I can put in a a little uh
advertisement now for dick seitz's new
book on uh how how to test distributed
systems
which is a uh a jewel of a book that as
far as I can know only a very small
number of people are reading and they
all need to everyone needs to read it
it's really carefully thought through
attack on how to make things work
and you know that's uh that's it's
important
on top of that you know at least I I
noticed because I use I use the uh the
information on the internet
uh very heavily in the stuff I do
um I find that you know the the the
whole structure that the the there was a
big push to get everything online and
make it work and now it's uh just uh
being allowed to deteriorate yeah yes
and so you know what used to be a stable
a stable system
for propagating information it no longer
works
that's
that is a big problem uh
and then there are forces like have
surrounding now the internet archive
which is doing absolutely
incredibly great work
and you know capturing and keeping at
least some of what we have learned in in
a form that can be disseminated and then
but they're arguing that well no they
shouldn't be allowed to do that because
it infringes possibly somebody's
copyrights and that sort of thing at
some point in time and etc etc one could
be generous and say it's copyright issue
I think there's also a bit of uh if you
save everything it's very hard to lie
about what's been done
that's true I think is someplace in
there is that you notice that in um in
the current Riot over uh cryptocurrency
exchanges which is
we'll get into uh the uh people are
trying to make things that they said
disappear from Twitter like make it go
away
I see and yet and then that's exactly
the thing that that I don't know whether
he archives Twitter stuff I think
probably not yeah it does it does then
they have a full fee
okay then in fact uh I should I haven't
talked to him about that in a long time
but uh this desire to make things
disappeared in the 1984
Volkswagen over 1984 World the people
would like to put us in where you can
just sort of rip up the past and
reconstitute it
uh
and people will forget the past I think
is is yeah internet archived uh that's a
spectacular job there it's spectacular
not only that it's uh you know as a
force for more for moral good it's
definitely uh I should know I've been on
the board of eff now for more years than
I can remember and we we uh we help them
as much as we can
[Music]
yeah but the the uh that brings up
another subject which I'm not sure we
want to go into today and that's the
whole social network issue
um that's that's worthwhile but we
should probably schedule another another
talk about that particular issue
um I I got sort of collecting a small
Cadre of people to look into what might
be done to replace Twitter
um I don't think any of the Twitter
clones are really going to make it
and the um the thing which uh seemed
most
desirable
was a suggestion that John Markov made
that uh what we really ought to do is we
got to figure out a way whereby uh
authorized
certified news sources
uh can in fact transmit news and
transmit it uh without any modification
uh and a I am real stamp
over the over the over the Internet we
don't have a mechanism that can do that
these days uh yeah that's one of the
projects to my center and KO is is the
future of Journalism
uh we've been a start a major project
we're just looking at the issues Man by
journalists
did you did you did you talk Kevin upper
ready to meet and talk with Frederick
sidou when he was at Stanford
I think so I'm not sure
he was uh he's French obviously yeah and
uh he uh he was in a night scholar
and was trying to build a system which
used uh some machine learning and lots
of people time to uh to decide whether
or not uh a
a
well it didn't have to be exact it was
sort of a coloration whether it was a
likely likely true story or a likely
false story or somewhere in between and
it was fairly successful
but enormously uh costly in terms of
people time
also uh you know
social networks of business
uh straight news straight on on polished
news is doesn't attract a large number
of people
I guess so uh controversy attracts
attracts people
now if you look at newspapers uh
you know times have suffered incredibly
by being relatively uh
opinion free they report the news
uh paper places like
well Fox News and others uh
where they they encourage controversy
because controversy brings people and
then the online social networks bringing
people makes Revenue
and that's that makes it difficult uh
yeah
I
boy that's that's just a that whole
thing deserves a separate talk I've uh
thought about what to do for years as
you know my ipus which is sort of tape
it off a little bit with my time uh I
took one path which says you know that
there was an editor namely me and I was
the only one who proposed so I was
grandfilter
uh that that got motivated by a book in
1930s uh socialist book uh I forget the
name of it but um uh which proposed that
the way people got their news is they
take some of their disposable income and
hire an editor
and as long as that editor satisfied his
customers he would get enough money to
live with that type of of game oh
so it's a curator of the of your room
yeah which is essentially what I do now
uh
I try to filter out things which are
just
provocative without contributing
anything uh
and for I still have a fair number of
people
I forget how many but it's a large
number of people
well is is the is the base of people
still growing
is slowly growing slowly you know
there's a
mostly because the they populate the
people have gotten old
as all of us and young people are not
motivated to using as much email
if I put that online and one of the
things I've been vaguely thinking of is
trying to
you know
put it more online but then I don't know
how to moderate it easily
nor do I know how to pass it on to
somebody else when I eventually
hang up
because it very much depends on the
editor
mm-hmm of if I was replaced by somebody
who uh
had different opinions or wanted to had
opinions that he would wanted to enforce
my attitude was was it still is any
valid opinion is worthwhile
yeah okay I just filled out that the
endless noise that comes in social
networks but then we're getting off to
another space we could also have an
interesting meeting of what the hell
talk of what the hell is happening
inside in cyber currency space
you know that's that's that's very
interesting uh they're they're they're
strong beliefs that people hold that are
just plain not true
I mean the the idea that the blockchain
somehow provides you the security is uh
well it's not true it's not true yeah uh
no I I'm a big fan of capability
architectures
uh
now and I've I've focus on at least
three capability Architects
architectures none of which may market
for interesting reasons uh but I always
felt that that you know that does
roughly the same stuff that blockchain
purports to do and does it correctly
yeah
one of those one of those systems you're
talking about is uh John Shapiro's PhD
work yeah yeah yeah well you know he's
now off building factories and making
dog collars and buttons and
uh you know being an active entrepreneur
yeah uh he's his his incredible
operating system Eros
um is sitting on GitHub
um not being exploited by anybody which
is really really quite sad yeah I
co-authored some of those papers if you
remember I know I'm well aware of that
yeah uh
I I think that's a direction well that's
what the direction that uh Cherry is
going basically in reconstructing uh
well I yeah anyway
that whole area I gave the first the
first capability architecture conference
I gave the keynote on that like many
many years ago I still think it's an
excellent idea especially if you put it
in Hardware
we don't that it's consumer of Cycles
so what we have Cycles to burn
yeah it doesn't have to consume oh it
doesn't have to man because it's it's
it's so in it's so
intertwingled to use Tag Nelson's term
with the memory management system that
has to be there anyhow right uh it's not
such a it's not such a cost
it's not much of a cost and and it's uh
and even if it was an incremental cost
so what
yeah you know we've right now we have
some of the fastest idle Loops going
so I I've been pushing that uh yeah
blockchain does make a huge amount of
sense the the damn then Gilmore and I
wrote an op-ed for um Nikkei Asia uh
well six months ago or so which
basically said you're out of your mind
guys and uh that's what happened
recently
now if it's
anyway it just happened it didn't happen
just happened yeah
I should resurrect that and say look we
told you so but so what uh
I mean I really believe in a utility for
cyber
for uh
let me call it cyber currency in the
banking systems
and in fact Japan is going to start one
with the package ban and several of the
big
banking systems in in Japan in the
beginning of the year you'll be able to
do the equivalent of cyber money
essentially uh rapid transfer which
Japan basically needs it it has it's
it's strange place here uh if I can
spend a minute on that yeah for a place
that's that's high tech in many ways
it's low-tech in other ways
the banking system is is
sort of strange compared to the US
there's a lot it's very hard to to pay
things
to the banking system but it's easy to
pay things to the convenience stores
uh you know there are no checks
if you want if I want to transfer money
from my account to your account I have
to go through some funny mechanisms that
just
uh reasonably opaque
uh if I'm gonna transfer overseas it's
really opaque but that's for a number of
reasons
but the uh
they're off something like six or seven
widely uh used uh electronic Payment
Systems in Japan everything from the the
transportation ticketing thing yeah it's
weaker impossible which I use to get on
subways but are accepted all over the
place the payment of everything you want
you know really easily uh and yet a
majority of Japanese seem to pay want to
pay in cash which is sort of
it's very traditional Society in some
ways a very advanced than others uh but
I really believe that the although I I
don't own Banksy stocks that I know of
uh that lubricating the ease of payment
is going to happen
yeah
and it's happening but that doesn't
that's independent of cyber currency and
and you know Bitcoins and everything
which I
have concern about yeah well as I
remember even I worked in a private
Financial project in Japan at one point
um and um
we look carefully at the Japanese credit
cards situation which is from a credit
card vendor or user's point of view a
total disaster it doesn't work well it
does work but it doesn't work very well
it doesn't work very well it is hard
certainly it's a fallen and it's an act
of desperation to get a credit card here
I think they expect you to leave the
country
instantaneously as soon as you get spend
some money you know that's getting you
know as as an employee of ko it's easy
but for instance I tried to get an
American Express card here and they
wouldn't give it to me even though I
have a platinum card in the U.S with uh
you know uh it's just I'm I'm not a per
I'm not a Japanese resident
yeah I'm a resident but not a permanent
and obviously I'm going to skip the
country
it is it's ridiculous uh and in the in
actual fact you know one of the things
that the project I worked on was was
wanting to do is to build a a uniform
worldwide uh banking system which uh
operated entirely electronically without
human intervention yes yeah
uh and that was that was that was uh
ultimately proved to be totally
impossible not because of anything that
had to do with what could be built and
what couldn't be built or the you
couldn't even you could maintain the
security of the system but what you
couldn't do is meet the requirements
built into the laws of the various
countries about laundering money yes yes
and transferring money was not really
considered a good thing now if you want
a mechanism to broadcast Western culture
a uniform currency might actually go far
better than anything else I can think of
agreed but the laws now I say while
since I'm an employee of ko University
that is I use the bank that they have an
affiliation with and all the employees
snbc
it's their code it's their Bank yeah uh
the banking divisions in Japan confused
me uh
yeah
other than that I'd have a hard time
getting a bank account mainly because of
the overhead of satisfying the US laws
on uh reporting and money hot watering
Etc yeah I'm talking to the amount of
paperwork that the bank has to do means
that it has to have a fairly large
population of foreign
um people in order to
afford to do it
uh
but yeah it's it's very strange uh but
anyway uh there's a lot of subjects I'd
love to do endlessly talk about but you
mentioned at the beginning education
yeah
let me let me make a couple comments uh
and uh realize that these comments are
from an American living in Japan and and
they may be completely different if I
was Japanese
living here
um
here and
I think that the the at least the people
the
environment I live in
uh
it's not clear how you do real graduate
work here
in our field
um
the support mechanisms are there the the
equivalent of NSF isn't there while
there are fellowships it's they're hard
and people are encouraged to go for
their master's degree
and a master's degree at least in the
areas I know here are heavy thesis
related
which you know is sort of the opposite
of the U.S
and at least the schools I've been out
in the U.S
you you even picked a PhD program in a
master's program
and you can in most cases you can't just
slide after through the Masters into the
PhD
no and uh and I think that that uh acts
as a a bad filter for
um
for the uh for getting uh
really Advanced people graduating from
the Japanese at least the schools I know
of in Japan now that you know I've just
made a broad thing and I know people
will say no no that's not the way it
happens but that's again my perception
of things uh there's not the motivation
for for going on to real Graduate
Studies but my by my definition of real
Graduate Studies
and uh suddenly Master's thesis is not
the same as PhD thesis
no and the the other thing which I
remember from I was mostly aligned with
people in Japan
uh the um
the the people who were most successful
at creating uh uh science and Engineers
were uh ran their little tiny piece of
ko University uh this is isil
um as a um a a a a branch of a western
research University and not a Japanese
University
and then of course there are people in
the University of Tokyo which have very
different view of how universities ought
to work and was basically quite
exclusive yeah yeah
uh
it doesn't I don't see the production of
people
uh certainly that the US universities
produce
uh where now the best description I I
sent to a student a very very good
student one of the best I've ever
encountered as he was an undergrad in
economics and got interested in crypto
Finance no not
and uh wrote of really good papers
undergraduate and I encouraged that he
was going to go get a job or something I
encouraged him to think of a PhD
talking into it and we applied to a
number of U.S schools
he got into Carnegie Mellon
okay uh and he's done spectacularly good
but just watching him adapt to the U.S
system has been intriguing okay he said
the first class he went to
it was a shell shock because the
students were actually questioning the
teacher
again the interaction style is is
completely different
and uh I think ISO did a lot
towards that towards helping but I think
it really requires something that starts
and probably the the grammar school
mm-hmm well his isils isil was very
unusual in that you know he his group of
students his first
cohort of graduate students uh you know
which of which there were seven
every single one of them was a star yes
and you know they formed what we see as
the the understructure of the uh uh the
computer systems studies in Japan today
and they went everywhere and did
everything and
and it was he really his his command of
English
which was not the best in the world but
it was quite adequate uh which which did
a big thing he and monoka and Yamada uh
they they had a huge impact on computer
science worldwide yes yes I uh
you know I first met isil when he asked
to come to my lab in Irvine
for he was an assistant professor
he spent a month with us and that
started a long term in fact I saw he's
still around
not you know he's getting old as all of
us are
and I saw him for a while while I was
here
uh but yes I mean he he watched a whole
set of students
which became leaders
the the funding system here is is
not as good as the US
It's relatively difficult to get funding
uh
salaries are
not that good graduate students are not
well paid paid at all
if paid at all
and uh you know for for a country that
really needs to get its technical act
back in year
I think it's going to take some some
major changes
which I I try to do you know as much as
I can
well you
it's
it's a very different Society Dave yeah
I know I know but it's it's really quite
amazing do professors still have the uh
the ability to be uh wild and unruly and
quite un
Untamed relative to the business
community
uh yeah as far as I can tell yes
uh the thing I love it's at Ko by the
way which is relatively unique is the
faculty elect the president
oh really yeah now you got to be careful
because it gets ratified by the Board of
Trustees which tend to be people who
drive around in very luxurious
limousines uh but but basically in
faculty
um uh elect there's an election there
are nominees
and they elect them and then I think uh
usually the Board of Trustees says yes
now that's a total different thing
and it can oscillate hysterically
because
universities or universities uh the pre
the one that was President kale when I
came here was I believe in his story and
very good historian the current one is
is basically a Quantum Computing person
with an excellent knowledge of English
his English is better than mine
uh
but uh
it's it's
I really shouldn't talk that much
because again I'm not even though I'm
I'm a distinguished Professor there are
two of them like KO right now I think
we're three
um I really don't
get much contact with the academic
Administration side of the game which is
something I've I've tried to stay clear
in my career anyway
I I think that's uh
emulated you in this that particular
regard
I remember the comment that uh New York
Times quoted uh
feinerman
Richard Phineas they asked him not in
paraphrasing here uh so U.S Nobel Prize
winner how come you've never been
president chairman of the physics
department of Caltech and Feynman said
again uh paraphrasing that every time I
think they're thinking about that I
stopped missing meeting losing papers
following up things pretty soon they
decide we don't want him
happy
right I haven't quite gotten that far
but I try very hard not to be too
confident in that uh
well you know it turns out that that's
not impossible and
your work is just that's right that's
right incompetence comes with with the
territory